Christiana Figueres: There's no doubt
that we are facing exponential
impacts of climate change.
There is also, however, no doubt
that that is being met
with exponential progress
of the technologies that can help
to address climate change.
So what we have here is, frankly,
a race between two exponential curves.
By 2030,
we collectively will have chosen
between door number one.
And door number two.
Julio Friedmann: The question
I am most commonly asked
about climate change is:
"Should I be optimistic or pessimistic?"
Cynthia Williams: Here's what
we need to do to make sure
that we're ready
for an all-electric future.
Anika Goss: Being financially secure
and climate resilient
should be the most important priority.
Faustine Delasalle: It's really easy
when you look at where we are today
and where we ought to be by 2030,
to feel like there's a huge gap
that will never be filled.
But we have good reasons to say
that that gap is actually fixable.
Nigel Topping: If you're not
worried or anxious,
you're probably not paying attention.
But we should also not be defeatist.
We shouldn’t say, “We’ve done nothing,
we're failing."
We've really started 20 years too late,
but it takes a long time to get
the flywheel of momentum going.
Kingsmill Bond: The tide
of change is coming.
The costs keep falling.
The political pressure keeps increasing.
JF: We're going to build
a thriving, exciting world.
AG: We can do this.
JF: Full of potential.
AG: We have to do this.
[TED Explores A New Climate Vision]
Manoush Zamorodi:
When it comes to climate change,
are you an optimist or a pessimist?
News about the climate
can be overwhelming and emotional,
to the point that many of us
just feel numb.
I’m Manoush Zomorodi, a longtime
public media journalist
and host of the TED Radio Hour.
And today, we want
to bring you something special:
an hour of nuance, of real people
and clarity about what
is happening to our planet
and what we're doing about it.
Because we all know there's plenty of bad
news when it comes to the climate crisis.
But guess what?
There's also some really good news.
That's why we're here in Detroit
at the TED Countdown Summit,
where a cross-section of people
who know the most
and who are doing the most
have gathered to share their ideas
and plans with each other
and with you.
You're going to hear
from some incredible speakers
about their personal stories
and tested solutions.
But first, let's get a quick
reminder on the basics:
climate change in a minute or so.
[Prologue: What is Climate Change?]
David Biello: The air we
breathe has changed.
The mix of gases is shifting,
with more and more greenhouse gases
like carbon dioxide.
And the shift is happening
faster each year.
In just a few hundred years,
fossil fuels formed over eons
have been burned as coal, oil and gas.
The exhaust has transformed
the entire atmosphere and ocean.
It's like a pollution blanket.
And the result we know as climate change.
The planet has already warmed
more than one degree Celsius
and is on a path to heat up even more.
That may not seem like a lot,
but it's already caused major
destruction across the globe.
To give us some room to breathe,
the world must reduce
greenhouse gas pollution
by more than seven percent each year,
every year of this decade.
There are a number of ways to do that.
Let's start by looking
at the greenhouse gases themselves.
CO2 makes up nearly 75 percent
of the pollution emitted each year.
And then there's methane or natural gas,
which makes up 17 percent.
Finally, there's nitrous oxide,
making up six percent of the problem.
There are other greenhouse gases,
but these three make up the bulk
of the climate challenge.
Where do they come from?
There are several ways to break down
the sources of greenhouse gas emissions.
Here we’re using the public
Climate Watch data.
Start with energy.
The majority of modern energy
comes from burning fossil fuels,
which makes the energy sector 76 percent
of the climate challenge,
including the fuels
used for transportation,
industrial processes
and agricultural production.
Farming and animal raising
also have to change,
as agriculture accounts for 12 percent
of greenhouse gas pollution.
The remaining 12 percent
comes from a grab bag of human activities
like industrial heating,
clearing forests and more.
This is the climate challenge we face:
going from adding billions
of metric tons of greenhouse gases
to the air each year to adding zero.
Will it be easy?
No.
Can we do it?
Yes, if we choose to.
MZ: OK, so that's the situation.
Where do we go from here?
Well, we've all heard of a tipping point,
that moment when an idea
or concept finally takes hold
and then changes the world.
Well, the UN's climate chief,
Simon Stiell,
believes we are almost at a tipping point
for massive action on climate change.
And to get you ready, he wants
to take you back to the early '90s,
when he was an executive at Nokia,
and the world wasn't sending
text messages yet.
[Chapter 1: Exponential Change]
Simon Stiell: I want you
to imagine it’s 1992,
and you're talking to a telecoms expert.
She tells you that mobile
phone text messaging
is going to fundamentally change
the way we communicate.
You think, why on Earth
am I going to go from this
to tapping on a screen
with my fingers and my thumbs?
But then, after a slow start,
text-based services exploded.
Today, over 23 billion messages
are sent every single day.
This paved the way
for the smartphone revolution.
I know how much we struggle to comprehend
and predict what exponential change means,
because I was at Nokia in 1993
when that technological
revolution started.
And now, as head of UN climate change,
I'm here to tell you that what
was true for mobile phones
is also true for climate action today.
We're here in Detroit,
the heart of car manufacturing.
Take a look at this graph.
Electric vehicle sales
are expected to increase
to become 70 percent by 2030.
Another example, solar energy.
Between 2010 and 2020,
we moved from 20 gigawatts
of solar energy installed
to 150 gigawatts.
And by 2030, that number
is expected to increase again,
to 1,000 gigawatts per year.
Change can come fast.
FD: So exponential change means
that change happens very slowly at first
and then comes a tipping point.
And suddenly things accelerate
and accelerate and accelerate.
NT: It's a mathematical term,
but it means basically
stuff happens very slowly
and then it goes really fast.
Tessa Kahn: Governments and experts
have consistently underestimated the pace
and scale at which we can
deploy renewable energy
and how quickly renewable energy
and associated technologies
become affordable.
Ramez Naam: I predicted in 2011
that we'd have solar as cheap as coal
in some parts of the world by 2015
and half the cost of coal by 2020,
and everyone thought I was crazy,
I've got to say, almost.
And in fact, I was wrong.
The actual decline in the cost of solar
happened twice as fast
as I thought it would.
Solar prices today are a century ahead
of where the world's leading energy
experts thought they'd be in 2010.
KB: It's now spreading from solar,
so it's happening also in the wind sector,
it's happening in the battery sector,
it's happening in the electric
vehicle sector.
CF: I don't think that we do
a good job at communicating the fact
that we are progressing
more than is commonly known.
Nili Gilbert: The human brain
is trained best
at thinking about linear change.
But when you think
about an exponential curve,
next to a line,
at first the exponential curve
is below the line,
and so it's moving more slowly
than you would think.
And then it crosses the line
and it's moving faster
than you would think.
Habiba Daggash: We call it
cautious optimism.
We're very hopeful
about the trajectories that we've seen.
But we shouldn't let up yet.
KB: So we can make this change happen slow
or we can make it happen fast.
The key point to say is we have agency.
MZ: This idea of exponential
growth sounds awesome.
It sounds amazing,
but is it actually happening?
Well, I'm headed into a workshop
with industry and climate leaders
to find out.
The moderators of the workshop
challenged us to hold two competing ideas
in our minds at the same time.
NT: What we're really
going to explore today
is two apparently opposing realities,
and they're often two opposing narratives.
The one which is true, right,
is that in terms of the Paris goals,
we're way off track.
We're deep into the emergency.
But what we're going to explore today
is the other reality
that we know what to do.
Exponential change is happening,
but it doesn't happen by magic.
MZ: So what are we seeing
in different industries?
Well, let's start with one
that's known to be really difficult
to decarbonize: cement.
Vicente Saiso Alva: I think everything
converges into making climate
a huge urgent matter for society.
We started to feel the pressure
from all different types of stakeholders,
and in one year of running this program,
we realized how fast we could move
and how fast we were going
in reducing CO2 emissions,
which means now to go from 40
to close to 50 percent reduction by 2030.
MZ: Encouraging, but to tackle
that remaining 50 percent
may require technologies
that don't exist at scale yet.
OK, what about shipping?
Narin Phol: In Maersk, a few years back,
we came out with a net-zero
ambition by 2050,
and in a few years later,
based on the data that we have got,
we've really seen a path
that we can really accelerate that one.
That's why the revised target
of 2040 came in.
MZ: The news in offshore wind
was quite dramatic.
Jennie Dodson: So my moment
of mindset shift was in 2019.
The government put out a request
to bid for offshore wind permits.
And that year the price that came in
was two thirds less
than just four years before.
And really critically,
it was the same price
as the mainstream market.
And that was transformative.
Nobody expected that when they started.
MZ: The conversation got pretty
technical and a bit wonky.
NP: So to drive exponential growth,
you focus on a reinforcing loop
to make sure it works
and you slow down on the balancing loop.
MZ: But the takeaway is
that certain sectors,
like EVs and renewables,
are being upended,
while others, like cement
and heavy industry
are further behind.
But generally across every industry --
JD: It’s amazing stuff.
MZ: There's an understanding
that they all need to work together.
And the message?
Big change can happen.
It's going to be hard, but some of us
are already doing it,
so learn from us.
[Chapter 2: The Electric
Vehicle Revolution]
OK, we are in an exponential mindset.
And as you heard,
one example of exponential growth
might be sitting
in your driveway right now.
Electric vehicles are finally
really happening,
which means that people here in Detroit
are rethinking the auto industry.
They're rethinking
their jobs, their identity.
Take Cynthia Williams,
head of sustainability at Ford.
I sat down with her at Lucky Detroit,
a local coffee and barber shop,
where she told me that there are three
things that need to happen
for electric vehicles to go
to the next level,
from this tipping point
to exponential growth.
CW: The three things for me are change,
collaboration and capacity.
So the change piece of it is changing
the way folks think about the vehicle,
making sure that they understand
we're bringing a better vehicle
to the customers.
MZ: So you don't have to make a sacrifice.
CW: I think one of the things
we need to do is actually
get people in the cars
and show them how fun it is.
And it's no different,
it's just powered by a battery.
We are at a tipping point.
We're at a point of acceleration
of electric vehicles.
Many are calling it
the electric vehicle revolution.
Now with that comes unprecedented change
that will require us to build new capacity
and collaborate in ways
that we've never seen before.
To make things happen faster,
you have to think differently.
You can't just collaborate
with the same people
because you get the same answer, right?
You need to broaden
your collaboration space.
Go outside of your industry,
understand what worked
in Norway, for example,
to get them to where they are.
MZ: Where's the weak link, Cynthia?
What's the thing that you're like,
that if we don't push through that,
we may not get to this full adoption?
CW: The critical things
that we hear from the consumers
is they need infrastructure.
That's what it's taking for us
to work with governments
to make sure that we bring
more charging to everyone,
whether it's rural, urban,
wealthy, low-income, we all need chargers.
And I'm not saying we need one
on every corner,
but we do need many, many more.
When we start building out the charging
infrastructure, we need lighting.
We need, you know, security,
shelter, we need restrooms.
We need other amenities
so that people know
where to go, where to charge.
Next comes capacity.
We have to invest
in new facilities and talent.
Now, that's true for any industry
transitioning to greener goals
and strategies.
And we're investing in talent,
we're investing in education and training,
and we're also listening
to the communities
where we live and operate.
MZ: So a young Cynthia Williams, now,
your counterpart
who's studying engineering,
will she be learning
something very different
if she wants to go and work
in the automotive industry in Detroit?
CW: There will be
different options, right.
And so, I'm a mechanical
engineer by trade,
but I think there will be opportunities
for electrical engineering,
software engineering.
And there's even certificates
that students can get
instead of going through
a four-year college.
It's the proper training to get
them right, to be dedicated,
to build the vehicles
that we need for the future.
At the end of this year, globally,
we’ll have the ability to produce
600,000 electric vehicles.
And in 2026, we’ll have a global goal
to produce two million electric vehicles.
And it just goes up from there.
MZ: What is this going to look like,
this growth for me in the next couple
of years, in five years, in 20 years?
CW: Clean air.
That's what I look at.
If you think about when we
were, during the pandemic,
when everybody stopped driving
and they were at home,
clear skies and moving to zero
tailpipe emission vehicles.
And if you chose an electric vehicle,
that's you participating
and you contributing to a better world,
to a better future.
We have come a long way.
It's so gratifying to see
electric vehicles on the road,
to move from aspiration to reality.
To see plants dedicated
to building electric vehicles.
We have the technology,
we have the leadership,
we have the ingenuity to respond
to the environmental crisis with courage.
And I'll tell you, as a person
who's dedicated my entire career
to sustainability,
the road ahead is paved with promise.
(Applause)
TED-Ed: If you were
buying a car in 1899,
you would have had three major
options to choose from.
You could buy a steam-powered car,
typically relying on gas-powered boilers.
These could drive as far as you wanted,
provided you also wanted to lug
around extra water to refuel
and didn't mind waiting 30 minutes
for your engine to heat up.
Alternatively, you could buy
a car powered by gasoline.
However, the internal combustion
engines in these models
required dangerous hand cranking to start
and emitted loud noises
and foul smelling exhaust while driving.
So your best bet was probably
option number three:
a battery-powered electric vehicle.
These cars were quick to start,
clean and quiet to run,
and if you lived somewhere
with access to electricity,
easy to refuel overnight.
If this seems like an easy choice,
you're not alone.
By the end of the 19th century,
nearly 40 percent
of American cars were electric.
In cities with early electric systems,
battery-powered cars were a popular
and reliable alternative
to their occasionally
explosive competitors.
But electric vehicles
had one major problem.
Batteries.
MZ: Flash forward to the present
and batteries are still
on everyone's mind.
So I visited Mujeeb Ijaz,
the founder of the energy
storage company One,
who also happens to be
an electric vehicle history buff.
Mujeeb Ijaz: So this
is a 1922 Detroit Electric.
MZ: OK, so 100-year-old vehicle.
MI: That's right, electric vehicle.
And then this was Walter Baker.
He developed the Baker Electric.
And he made the range run
201 miles on a single charge.
He also felt strongly that you should
be able to wear your top hat, you know,
so he has a taller carriage.
These had lead acid
batteries to begin with.
And then Thomas Edison
introduced the nickel-iron battery.
So this is the battery compartment,
one of the battery compartments.
And this is where you would charge.
MZ: Right there?
MI: And we're building
on what these original pioneers did.
And I think it's important to not think
about us starting from scratch now.
But go backwards,
think about how they solved the problem,
what disrupted their ability
to advance this to the market,
and then pick those problems up
and make sure we don't get stuck again.
MZ: So we've been here before,
a moment when electric vehicles
could have taken off but didn't.
So what do we need to do
differently this time?
MI: Electric vehicles were able to deal
with mobility in urban areas,
but there were charging deserts
where rural driving resulted
in no way to get back
because you couldn't find
electric charging everywhere.
And that was a problem.
MZ: And that's what people
are worried about right now.
We're at the same thing.
We're worried about range,
we're worried about accessibility.
All of the things are the same.
But the key difference being
that we now know
that our planet
can't keep going like this.
MI: That's right.
Had the vision
of the Model T assembly line
and mass manufacturing
been applied to electric car,
the electric car would have
also dropped in price,
but range and charging deserts
would have still been the obstruction.
MZ: OK.
We didn't have the technology,
but we do now.
MI: We do now.
MZ: In the US, there hasn’t been
a mass move to electric vehicles ... yet.
Mujeeb's company is one of many who want
to change that by building batteries
that give drivers longer range.
And these batteries aren't just for cars.
MI: So we produce battery packs
for transportation,
but we've also started developing
the same battery products
into grid batteries.
So micro-grids are those technologies
that combine solar and storage
and replace a coal plant
or a natural gas plant
for generating electricity.
So buildings and industry
and transportation all working together.
And that's an exciting future, is all
these industries working together,
that makes me more confident
that we're at the time in history
where this transition will take place.
MZ: How many years till we get to that?
MI: I think it's within 10 years.
MZ: No way, 10 years?
MI: We're in a place where that transition
is going to be much more visible,
and then we just need technologies
to drive it up to the mass markets.
MZ: I am so excited.
Like, genuinely so excited.
Everyone everywhere
driving electric sounds great,
but that also means that the power
to charge all those vehicles
needs to be green.
And that brings us to the energy sector,
which is also changing
at an incredible pace,
even though renewable energy
has been years in the making.
[Chapter 3: Renewables]
TED-Ed: In the spring of 1954,
the press excitedly gathered
around Bell Laboratories’
latest invention:
a silicon-based solar cell
that could efficiently convert
the sun's energy into electrical current.
The creation was celebrated
as the dawn of a new era,
as reporters touted
that civilization would soon run
on the sun's limitless energy.
But the dream had a catch.
As this first commercially sold solar cell
cost around 300 dollars per watt,
meaning at its current rate it would cost
well over a million dollars
to buy a unit large enough
to power a single home.
But today, in many countries,
solar is the cheapest form
of energy to produce,
surpassing fossil fuel alternatives
like coal and natural gas.
Millions of homes are equipped
with rooftop solar,
with most units paying for themselves
in their first seven to 12 years
and then generating further savings.
So how did solar become so affordable?
A turning point in solar's price history
occurred on the floor
of Germany's parliament,
where in 2000, Hermann Scheer introduced
the Renewable Energy Sources Act.
This legislation laid out a vision
for the country's energy future
in solar and wind.
It incentivized citizens to personally
invest in rooftop solar panels
by guaranteeing payment to homeowners
for the renewable energy they generated
and sold to the grid.
The pay rate for this electricity
was highly subsidized,
at times reaching four times
the market price.
Several other countries soon
followed Germany's example,
implementing similar
policies and incentives
to drive their country's solar use.
This created unprecedented demand
for solar panels worldwide.
Manufacturers were able
to scale up production
and innovate in ways that cut costs.
As a result, solar panel prices
dropped while efficiency grew.
HD: We see the cost reduction in solar
and other renewable energy
technologies has been so steep,
but a lot of it is because of the enabling
regulatory and policy environments
created in places like
the European Union and the US.
Akil Callender: We cannot divert
catastrophic climate change
without addressing emissions
coming from our energy systems.
Currently, emissions
from the energy system
account for around two thirds
of global greenhouse gas emissions.
So the good news is, yes,
we are seeing tremendous progress
across the globe in renewable energy.
It's rolling out faster than ever before.
Luisa Neubauer: The brilliant thing
about energy supply in the world
is that we have alternatives.
So we don't need fossil fuels
to provide safe and equitable
access to energy systems.
Ramón Méndez Galain: Almost 90 percent
of the total new installed capacity
all over the world is just renewable.
This is a tremendous change.
AC: There's more finance than ever before
going into clean energy.
In many countries, it is the largest
contributor to their electricity system
for the first time ever.
KB: And also because China is the leading
manufacturing nation in the world,
change is happening there much faster.
And those innovations
are then spreading around the world.
Hongquiao Liu: China's coal demand
might not have peaked,
and China will continue to consume
quite a lot of coal in the next few years.
But the decarbonization is happening.
It's happening faster
than anyone has expected,
and China is adding an astonishing
amount of wind and solar
to its grid every year.
Eduarda Zoghbi: I think one
of the biggest obstacles today
are natural resources,
in the sense that we're talking more
and more about critical minerals
and the role that they have.
And batteries are demanding
a lot of critical minerals
that are present in most
of the developing countries.
So I think that even though
costs are decreasing,
we have to be more and more creative
when it comes to recycling the batteries.
We also have to think of how
they're impacting local communities.
KB: So to give you the numbers,
we extract, at the moment,
15,000 million tons
of fossil fuels every year.
The International Energy Agency says
that we will need about 43 million tons
of critical materials
in order to build out
the clean energy economy.
So that’s 300 times less
stuff that is required.
It's worth saying that the impact
of extracting 300 times
less stuff upon nature
is dramatically lower.
And I know that it's often argued
that the renewable economy
may be damaging for nature.
Again, this is a completely
false statement.
It's in fact, our only chance of reducing
the pressure upon our natural resources,
because there's far less of it.
MZ: Of course, transitioning to using
clean energy, upending industries,
it has to happen across the world,
not just here in the US.
And it can be hard to even imagine
what life will be like.
But carbon scientist and futurist
Julio Friedmann can help us.
Julio Friedmann: I think we need
a compelling vision of the future
that gets people excited
about the energy transition
and solving climate change.
Right now, it's like we're at a restaurant
and there's two options:
burnt toast, unflavored oatmeal.
And people are not excited
about either, right?
The burnt toast option for me
is what I call the big switch.
Everything's the same, it's just clean,
but it costs a lot of money
and it's super hard to do.
The other vision is kind of
like, “Thou shalt not.”
That vision is a narrower sort of,
“eat your peas,” hair shirt
kind of vision of the future.
And a lot of people
don't want that either.
And there's nothing in the physics,
chemistry or biology
that says we can't have
a super interesting, exciting,
vibrant world.
And that is compelling in a way
that we have not heard yet.
MZ: Help me out here,
what does that even look like?
JF: So, for lack of a better word, like,
I like the Marvel cinematic universe.
MZ: OK, I'll go with you.
JF: So a place like Wakanda, right?
It's got flying cars,
it's got maglev trains,
and it's a totally fabulous place to live.
Like, they've got lots of food.
That is built on abundant,
sustainable, cheap energy.
MZ: OK, so like, we're not Wakanda,
we're not in the Marvel universe.
This is real life, sort of.
How do we make this possible?
JF: So what can you actually
do here on Earth,
constrained by economics and engineering
and all the rest of it, right?
And the answer is we can do
an incredible amount.
Abundant, available
where you want it, when you want it.
Everybody should have energy,
including the three billion people
who use less electricity
than my refrigerator uses.
Well, the good news is, every day,
the Earth receives 163,000 terawatts
of energy from the sun.
About half of that bounces back to space,
but about 80,000 terawatts
arrive at the Earth
in a form we can use.
For reference, today, the world uses
about 26 terawatts of energy,
and we got more than solar and wind.
We have geothermal,
we have hydro, we have nuclear.
There’s other kinds of clean energies.
And some of the best resources are,
in fact, in the Global South.
These places are not simply
future climate victims.
These places are latent
energy superpowers.
My favorite example of this is Chile.
Almost eight years ago now
their government said,
wait a second, we can make
the cheapest green electricity on Earth.
We have hydropower, we have solar power,
we have wind power and the best resources
anywhere in the world.
So let's start by making
a lot of green electricity.
And then they said, because of that,
we can also make green hydrogen
cheaper than anywhere else.
And then Japan was like, hello,
we want your green hydrogen.
Can you ship it to us?
MZ: Is that possible?
JF: Totally.
And Japan is like, we will also give you
money to pay for these projects.
We'll loan you money
to pay for these projects.
Could you please use Japanese technology?
So they're using Japanese
turbines, electrolyzers,
they're using Japanese ships
to haul the ammonia around.
So Japan gets rich on this,
Chile gets rich on this.
MZ: Win-win.
JF: Totally win-win.
MZ: Win-win-win, planet, too.
JF: And that model, other countries
are looking at that, going,
I want some of that.
And that's why I like
this vision of abundance.
15 years ago, solar
was the most expensive power.
Now it is the cheapest
form of electricity, right?
Which is astonishing,
it's totally amazing.
And a whole bunch of people
are like, now we're done.
And I'm like, no, we can do
that with everything.
We can do that with wind.
We can do that with nuclear,
we can do that with geothermal.
But these projects take time,
money and people.
We need to develop the human capital
as part of these investment
projects for decades.
And innovation,
we need much more energy
in many places, much cheaper.
That's an innovation agenda.
For solar, that was
the United States, Germany, China
and others acting together.
Well, if that's the recipe,
we can do that again.
We're already doing it with electric
vehicles and clean hydrogen production.
We can certainly do it
by turning electricity into fuels.
MZ: It sounds like the climate discussion
needs to be kind of like improv,
that it's a "yes and" sort of thing.
JF: I'm so glad you said that.
So many people don't understand
my love of improv comedy.
Yes, it is a “yes and” circumstance.
Because mostly it is
about room for agreement.
Where do you find the point
where everybody is like,
I can agree on that?
One of the things I love
about the infrastructure bill,
one of the things I love
about the Inflation Reduction Act,
neither of them had
the word climate in it.
They were both massive
climate bills, right?
That was a way to get everybody
on the same page.
Nationwide, they basically tripled
the clean energy research budget.
That's a good start.
But that made it all
of one percent of GDP.
And for comparison, we spend
twice that on pharmaceuticals.
So I think it's fair to say
we should get going.
We should spend a lot more money.
We've done stuff like this before.
We've done World War II,
we've done the Marshall Plan,
like, we’ve done the space shot,
like we actually know how to move
really quickly as a nation.
We did this for COVID.
Collective action,
building together is what makes
the difficult possible
and nourishes the soul
through mission and purpose.
We know what to do and we can act,
not out of anger or fear,
but out of generosity and common purpose,
bringing aspiration and humility together.
We're going to build a thriving, vibrant,
exciting world full of potential
that's going to be built
on the back of infrastructure,
innovation and investment
that will harness the abundant,
sustainable, cheap energy
that is our planet's endowment.
Thank you.
(Applause)
[Chapter 4: A Just Transition]
FD: There is a high risk
that when those exponential kick in,
we see businesses running
after those opportunities.
But then the distribution
of the benefits being very unequal.
EZ: Many people like
discussing the importance
of the just energy transition.
And a lot of people don't understand
what justice really means.
If we are to reach a revolution,
a renewable energy future
has to be inclusive.
AC: We have this push
for what we're calling a just
and equitable energy transition.
We need to make sure
that we are not exacerbating inequality,
but rather we are ensuring
that that gap is closed
and that the groups that have been
historically marginalized
are not once again being
marginalized in a new way.
NT: Most of emissions come
from wealthy, energy-guzzling citizens,
but a lot of the economic benefit
and human development benefit will come
not from decarbonizing
high-carbon lives and lifestyles,
but from providing clean,
distributed energy and tools
and solutions to those who don't
have access to any of them.
LN: When we speak of countries
in need of economic development,
we mostly speak of countries
that are hit by the climate crisis
the hardest right now.
It should be the biggest wish
and job and task
for all those countries who have burned
so much fossil fuel already
to support any other country
in the so-called Global South,
to get an economy running
without fossil fuels,
to not repeat all the mistakes
that we have made.
HD: To ensure that the solar revolution
that has been seen around the world
comes to places like Africa,
we need to be really conscious
that the history and the lived experience
when it comes to energy
is very different for poor countries.
Rebekah Shirley: We love to remind
Global South communities,
especially Africa,
about the vast renewable energy potential
that they have, which is true.
But the finance flows to deliver
on that potential remain very scarce.
Africa, despite being 90 percent
of those across the entire globe
that still do not have
access to electricity
and being 17 percent
of the global population,
we're actually two percent
of international finance.
Money doesn't actually flow
to these spaces naturally,
and we need to do a lot of work
to get global finance to these spaces.
MZ: A world of abundant
clean energy for everyone.
That is the goal.
But what about in the short term?
Take Detroit.
This once-wealthy city has been through
some seriously hard times.
How is it rebuilding itself
so that everyone here can thrive
while dealing with extreme heat, flooding,
and other climate problems?
Anika Goss is looking
to Detroit's past to plan its future.
AG: I am a third-generation Detroiter.
My grandmother moved to Detroit in 1936
during the Great Migration
and brought all
of her southern ways with her.
She owned a home
and knew that home ownership
would create wealth
and opportunity for her growing family.
Up until the late 1950s,
Detroit was a haven
for middle-class families
living in neighborhoods
where there was green space
and community connectivity
and opportunity.
My grandmother,
she had this amazing garden,
and it was just abundant.
There were all kinds of flowers and food.
You know, she grew vegetables back there,
and it was just a magical
place for a little girl.
MZ: I mean, what you're describing
is a Detroit that, yes, has huge problems,
segregation.
But at the same time, a woman,
she can have a job,
she can own a house,
she can raise her family,
she can have fresh fruits and vegetables.
AG: It was certainly a place where
you could gain economic opportunity
faster than you can now.
My grandmother's Detroit
is not the Detroit that I live in today.
All of those sites where
there was manufacturing
and industrial sites that led
to our economic boom,
many stand vacant and abandoned.
These industrial sites have led
to dangerous contamination
to our land and our water and our air.
MZ: So, just lay it out for us.
For people who maybe don't see,
like, how is there a link between
economic inequality and climate change?
AG: You know, I'm so surprised
that it feels like separate problems.
But I'm also really glad
that people are asking.
Because if you're living around
and working in a community
that is low-income,
where there are fewer jobs,
the housing is deteriorated,
this is a neighborhood that's also
more likely to be closer to a factory
that's emitting pollutants,
likely to have water that's contaminated,
probably has fewer parks
and fewer intentional green spaces.
The people who are living
in those communities
are at risk for climate impacts first.
So we have to do something
in those neighborhoods right away.
MZ: So what can this healthier
future look like?
Anika showed me some
of the work she's done
in partnership with different
neighborhoods in Detroit,
to make them both
more enjoyable and more resilient.
First, she took me to the Circle Forest.
It's an oasis right
in the middle of the city.
AG: This is six lots that were vacant,
and we all worked together
with this community to build a forest.
MZ: Beautiful and a great example
of how nonprofits can work
with communities
to transform them into sustainable,
welcoming places.
AG: We might have a good idea
about gardens and tree planting,
but this is where people live.
And so you ask first.
This is a new effort,
of this idea of a resilient
neighborhood or calling it that.
So these are large tracts of vacancy
that can be used to provide
environmental sustainability,
community resilience and beauty.
Watch for the poison ivy.
It's not pretend.
(Laughter)
MZ: Next we met up with Katrina Watkins,
the founder and CEO of the Bailey Park
Neighborhood Development Corporation,
a group revitalizing this historic area
by turning vacant lots into parks
that can stand up to extreme weather.
Katrina Watkins: My family has been
in this neighborhood since 1946.
I grew up hearing the stories from my dad,
him telling me about how people thought
it was a ghetto, but it wasn't.
Those were families, and people
worked and had businesses,
and people looked out for each other.
And it was those type of stories
that made me say,
wow, we just really need
to bring that back.
MZ: So then briefly fill us in
about how things changed.
KW: Things deteriorated
in this neighborhood.
The homes got torn down,
left just a lot of vacant lots,
a lot of overgrowth.
It wasn't safe.
I would see my little nieces and nephews.
They would just be
on their little skateboards,
you know, not paying attention,
the stop sign is covered.
And me and my dad was like,
we just have to do something.
So we started out as Bailey Park Project,
focusing on the park and green
infrastructure and trees and flowers.
And then over the course of the years,
we started doing
more community development.
MZ: I wonder, like,
how do you describe it to people
when you explain what's happening,
what you're trying to do
for your neighborhood,
the changes that you're making
and how it relates to climate change?
KW: One really great example,
when people come to the park,
like right now,
this is like, literally a heat island
because our trees haven't grown.
So it is very hot.
So sometimes it's so hot
that the kids don't come out
and play until the evening.
That education of knowing
the benefit of trees
and cooling down an environment,
how it makes the air cleaner.
There's a lot of people
that suffer from asthma.
So trees can make a difference.
And if you go to places
like Grosse Pointe,
you will see this beautiful
tree canopy down.
Like their homes are probably
20 degrees cooler
you know, than our homes,
AG: Having a lot of green space
actually contributes
to the climate resiliency
for this neighborhood.
So all of this grass actually
can manage stormwater better.
The idea of leading new development
in this neighborhood
with green,
what it says to me
is that the residents
are really envisioning
the neighborhood
that they want to live in.
And that I just -- I'm really
excited about that.
MZ: Turning great loss and upheaval
into even greater opportunities.
These Detroiters are creating
a blueprint for an urban future
that every city can learn from.
[Chapter 5: Agriculture]
TED-Ed: About 10,000 years ago,
humans began to farm.
This agricultural revolution
was a turning point in our history
that enabled people to settle,
build and create.
In short, agriculture
enabled the existence of civilization.
Today, approximately 40 percent
of our planet is farmland.
Spread all over the world,
these agricultural lands
are the pieces to a global puzzle
we are all facing.
In the future,
how can we feed every member
of a growing population a healthy diet?
Meeting this goal will require
nothing short of a second
agricultural revolution.
The first agricultural revolution
was characterized
by expansion and exploitation,
feeding people at the expense of forests,
wildlife and water,
and destabilizing the climate
in the process.
That's not an option the next time around.
Agriculture depends on a stable climate
with predictable seasons
and weather patterns.
This means we can't keep
expanding our agricultural lands,
because doing so will undermine
the environmental conditions
that make agriculture possible
in the first place.
Instead, the next agricultural revolution
will have to increase the output
of our existing farmland for the long term
while protecting biodiversity,
conserving water,
and reducing pollution
and greenhouse gas emissions.
So what will the future farms look like?
In Bangladesh, Cambodia and Nepal,
new approaches to rice production
may dramatically decrease
greenhouse gas emissions in the future.
Rice is a staple food
for three billion people
and the main source of livelihood
for millions of households.
More than 90 percent of rice
is grown in flooded paddies,
which use a lot of water
and release 11 percent
of annual methane emissions,
which accounts for one to two percent
of total annual greenhouse
gas emissions globally.
By experimenting with new strains
of rice, irrigating less
and adopting less labor-intensive
ways of planting seeds,
farmers in these countries have already
increased their incomes
and crop yields
while cutting down
on greenhouse gas emissions.
MZ: Related technologies
are also taking root in the US.
Father and daughter farmers,
Jim and Jessica Whitaker,
have come up with their own
strategies to reduce methane
that are working
on their farm in Arkansas.
But convincing everyone else to change
is their next big challenge.
So let's go back to how you got to be
such a big supplier of rice
in this country.
You tell a story about how you
were 22 and you were like,
I'm going to start my own farm, but --
not that easy.
Jim Whitaker: No, it's not.
Let me tell you something about renting
a farm when you're 22 years old.
No one rents you a farm
unless no one else wants to rent it.
(Laughter)
It was a big piece of land,
it was cash rent,
I mean, the stakes were set.
We were doomed to fail.
And we weren't focused on environmental
sustainability back then.
We were focused
on economic sustainability.
How do we make higher yield?
How do we use less fertilizer?
How do we get to the next year
and feed our family?
It happens that economic
and environmental sustainability
go hand in hand along
with social sustainability.
As we used less fertilizer,
used less water,
our yield started going up.
MZ: Can you spell out for me
what the problem is with rice
when it comes to the environment?
JW: Soil is full of microbes.
And what they're doing
in the soil on a basic level
is they're down there chewing away,
eating up the biomass
that's left over from the crop before.
And out of that comes methane,
the same way it happens in cattle
operations or whatever.
MZ: But you decided
to do it a different way.
JW: We do it a little bit differently.
Arkansas is a very water-rich state,
but we have a dry season,
right in the middle
of summer is a dry season.
So when we dry the soil,
that anaerobic microbial
that's living in that soup,
that mushy soil,
either dies or goes dormant.
So we break his life cycle.
MZ: Oh!
JW: And then it stops emitting methane.
But it doesn't hurt the rice.
That actually helps rice,
when you use less water.
We have less runoff, less erosion,
less nutrients leaving our field.
Nothing leaves our field
unless we want it to.
Jessica Whitaker Allen:
We started tracking this.
We saw that our water use
was down and we thought,
OK, well, we need to add to that,
let's add more data points to that.
Let's add our fertilizer,
let's add our fuel usage.
And so we really started recording
all this stuff by hand
in just an Excel spreadsheet.
We didn't know what we were doing.
MZ: But you knew you were on to something.
JWA: Yes, so we started
recording everything.
MZ: Do you remember if there was a moment
when the two of you thought, like,
what we're doing,
it shouldn't be special to us.
Why aren't more people --
JW: To collect the data,
have the equipment
and the cloud-based technology
and the stuff in the field to record it,
it’s just massively time-consuming,
and consumers don’t pay for it.
JWA: Well and people like us,
why would you want to do it?
I mean, take a walk
through your supermarket.
Everything’s sustainable,
everything’s greenwashed.
You can put whatever
you want to on a package,
there's no rules, there's no standards.
So we're trying to make that standard.
We live and work in southeast Arkansas.
Our town has 4,000 residents
and one stoplight.
The nearest airport, Starbucks
shopping mall, Whole Foods,
is two hours away in any direction.
Without places like this
and farmers like us,
you'd be hungry, naked and sober.
(Laughter)
I'm a farmer, but not in the way
you might think.
I don’t drive the tractors,
and I don’t plant the rice.
But I know how to take what my dad
has learned and what he is doing
and share that with others.
We are going to work with farmers
in southeast Arkansas
to educate them about the benefits
of growing sustainable rice.
JW: Let me tell you why that's important.
There are 400 million acres
of rice grown globally.
And our methods, if used, can reduce
greenhouse gas by 50 percent,
reduce water use by 50 percent,
increase yields to feed a hungry world.
(Applause)
MZ: We hear a lot about how weather
has gotten more extreme, flooding, heat.
What's it been like in Arkansas?
JW: So in 2016, we had a 500-year flood.
We were ...
We get a picture of our place flooded.
14 inches of rain.
That was a 500-year flood.
Hurt a lot of people.
And then we had a 1,000-year flood.
And we lost so many acres.
And you know, when houses
get flooded in rural communities,
they don't come back.
I mean, when you have
whole neighborhoods get flooded,
they don't rebuild them,
they don't come back.
JWA: I feel like almost every day
I'm getting a notification
from the weather Channel
of an excessive heat warning
or thunderstorm warning or hail threat.
You know, you don't really know
what you're going to expect.
MZ: When you think
about what it will be like,
I don’t know, five years, 10 years,
for someone to go into the supermarket
and think, oh, right,
I need to get rice off my grocery list.
What ideally would you like
to see on the shelf there?
JW: So I think it’s going to change,
because I like to study
what companies want.
I mean, if you figure out what they want,
then you know what to give them.
And when you read
their sustainability goals,
they're all saying
they're going to be net zero.
The only way they can be net zero
is they bring the farmer into the loop.
So if we're able to do this,
in five years, everybody's
doing these practices,
the US rice industry
will be the most sustainable
industry in the world.
MZ: Can you do it?
JW: Oh, yeah.
It's about to happen.
MZ: You've just heard a lot of ideas,
a lot of stories and a lot of big plans.
So we want to wrap things up
by asking our experts:
What if we actually achieved
our climate goals?
What would that future even look like?
They, of course, had a lot of thoughts.
We'll let you pick your favorites.
Thanks for watching.
NT: If we are successful
in addressing the climate crisis,
we massively reduce the vulnerability
and improve the economic
and the creative prospects
of billions of people around the world
who currently are basically excluded
from all of the opportunities
which we have,
which come from having abundant material
and energy all around us.
That's the real prize.
FD: A world where
we have had that exponential
would be a world in which we have
clean, cheap energy for all.
KB: At the end of this decade,
the International Energy Agency believes
that we will have enough capacity
to be producing 10 billion,
10 billion batteries a year.
It's enough for every person
on the planet to have their own battery.
AC: I'm constantly surrounded
by young people just like me
who are really, really, really passionate
about the world that we live in.
For obvious reasons.
It's the world that we will inherit.
EZ: Women are very important
for the energy transition.
So if we're talking about a world
where we have, you know,
where we tackle climate change,
all I want to see is, you know,
women in power.
I want to see more solutions
being driven by young people.
And I want our politicians to be truly
and meaningfully engaged in making change.
NG: We always tend to underestimate
the pace of ultimate adoption and change.
Today, there are more than 150 pathways,
scientific pathways that we could
take to limit global warming.
Al Gore: If we get to true net zero,
astonishingly, global temperatures
will stop going up
with a lag time of as little
as three to five years.
Colin Averill: We've been able
to accelerate tree growth
and carbon capture
and tree stems by 30 to 70 percent.
Dan Jørgensen: Offshore wind
has the potential
to cover the current electricity
demand of the entire world
not once, not twice,
18 times.
NG: We need to decarbonize
the old economy that we have
and invest to create
the new economy that we need
Paul Hawken: Regenerative farming
is fairly simple in concept.
It means creating
the conditions for more life.
Josephine Phillips: We need
to buy less stuff,
and we need to look after what we buy.
Valuing the things that we own
is a climate solution.
Vishaan Chakrabarti: We can all live
in this transit-rich, carbon-negative,
affordable way
and leave the vast majority
of the planet for nature,
for agriculture, for clean oceans.
We can do this.
Susan Ruffo: The ocean is
a powerful source of solutions
that we've overlooked for far too long.
Al Roker: You have to be engaged.
Let your elected officials know
that this is important to you.
You have to vote,
you have to go out there
and support politicians
who are going to support our planet.
Peggy Shepard: We can create
a legacy of environmental quality
and climate resilience for all.
Fehinti Balogun: You are not powerless
that the "oh, there's nothing we can do,
just keep going" is symptom,
not cure.
But you are needed.
Avinash Persaud: The power
of what we can do
when it matters to us is unlimited.
CF: It's not that we're
simply going to avoid
the worst impacts of climate change.
It’s that we’re going to improve
the quality of life for humans,
both in the urban and in the rural sector,
and for non-humans.